all'inizio fu il verbo e il verbo la
parola
sono le parole che cambiano il nostro
mondo la realtà in cui abitiamo mano
questo potere porta un esempio al 6 per
cento dei ragazzi sotto i 18 anni
oggi viene diagnosticato il disturbo
attentivo e l'iperattività una scatola
stretta dove incasellare quello che non
è conforme e non ci sono dubbi che se
fossi nata adesso sarei sicuramente è
stata certificata al meglio al meglio
alla stella maris il centro locale per
questo tipo di disturbi mia mamma invece
di farmi fare strani diagnosi risolveva
tutto prima dandomi un paio di
scappellotti e poi dicendo che avevo
l'argento vivo addosso e sentite già
così
quanta libertà invece lascia il modo con
cui chiamiamo le corse le cambia le
parole o danno o tolgono non sono mai
neutre e il disturbo non ci sono dubbi
toglie l'argento vivo da all'inizio fu
il verbo la parola la mia era argento
vivo infatti a me questo argento ha dato
tantissimo ha dato l'opportunità di
occuparmi di 100 cose mettere il naso in
10mila e farmi un milione e non ultimo
di crescere sulla punta delle dita
due coppie di gemelli nate in due anni
il modo con cui chiamiamo le cose le
cambia qualcuno l'ha chiamata una
catastrofe per me è stato il dono che ha
cambiato la mia vita e mi ha insegnato
un paio di cose
lasciatemi nel condividere fino a quel
momento la mia storia era una storia
come tante
lo studio l'università le amici le feste
feste e poi l'amore il fidanzamento il
matrimonio e poi come nelle migliori
tradizioni la gravidanza e tutti vissero
felici e contenti
invece no qui la cosa inizia ad
annodarsi il primo nodo sono due gemelli
e le prime informazioni che ricevo dagli
operatori tipo ginecologo ostetrica i
pediatri sono che i gemelli non nascono
quasi mai naturalmente ma soprattutto
che gemelli non si possono allattare
o meglio si possono allattare nessuno
l'ha mai visto fare il mondo definito
per me da qualcun altro
un'altra scafa un limite oltre il quale
sembra impossibile spingersi questo
verbo però andava in contrapposizione
con quello che diceva la mia nonna gilda
ormai novantenne borbottava sempre di
qualcosa di donne che se i tempi con una
manciata di fagioli riuscivano a
prendere a balia e allattare una schiera
di ragazzetti e che noi donne moderni
cresciute con le bistecche non fossimo
in grado di farlo neanche per un bambino
solo il verbo di non agita dentro di me
a creare la mia realtà riuscì ad
aiutarmi a vedere oltre la scatola oltre
l'orizzonte
io infatti ma davanti si sa sono un iter
attiva o meglio l'argento vivo addosso e
quindi lavoro faccio brigo folco mi
sento in forza e stop
benissimo la mia gravidanza è una
gravidanza
dico tutta soddisfatta
ecco però il secondo nodo uno dei
cuccioli a una malformazione e deve
essere operato appena nato
la cosa è grave e le parole il verbo
dicono che il 50 per cento dei nati con
questa malformazione non ce la fa
terzo nodo quella che fino a quel
momento momento sentivamo come una bella
cosa diventa invece un ulteriore
ostacolo i gemelli nascono prima e
quindi più piccoli e questo può mettere
ulteriore aggravio sull'operazione
questa nuova storia questa narrativa mi
sovrasta e la mia gravi dance diventa
una grave danza l'attesa si fa
opprimente insopportabile mi metterò a
casa buona buona a fare niente ma ormai
si sa che ferma non ci sto e quindi
inizia a leggere e studiare e conoscere
sapere informarmi e sapere diventa la
mia nuova ancora il mio modo di trovare
altre parole di segnare ancora un mondo
nuovo per me non mi trattengo su i
dettagli dell'operazione o del mese è
passato al meyer ma oggi cosimo è così
quindi
quindi come si fa a fianco quindi tutte
andate alla grande e lui ha incrementato
la casistica dei casi risolti ma quello
che mi è successo mentre eravamo in
ospedale è la storia che vi voglio
raccontare la più grande trasformazione
del mio mondo
la fase della vita in cui ho imparato
l'importanza di non voler fermare il
vento con le mani subito appena nato è
arrivato qualcuno che mi ha chiesto se
avrei allattato io ero molto confusa e
non lo sapevo mi ha precisato però che
se non l'avessi fatto vista la
situazione è molto delicata
avrei dovuto rimediare con dieci fra
integratori medicinali vari e ma a me le
doppie pesate biberon latte formulato mi
davano un idea di pesantezza di fatica
come avere il vento in poppa invece
andare a remi un giorno però finalmente
a casa mi sono seduta con i miei neonati
sul mio divano comodo
ho portato cose da mangiare cose da bere
musica libri telecomandi tablet e tutto
quello che pensavo mi sarebbe servito da
lì a un anno mi sono acciambellata come
in una cuccia e ho attaccato i miei
bimbi al seno
mio marito diceva che ci puzzava come
dentro una tana di una volpe
però ho detto a tutti che avevo
finalmente capito a cosa serve una mamma
e cioè allattare i nutrire i propri
cuccioli e che da quel giorno
chiunque mi avrebbe trovato lì
spiaggiata la sensazione di leggerezza
che ho provato è stata deflagrante e
spaventosa essere sospinti dal vento
senza opporre resistenza alcuna ho fatto
purtroppo tanti errori cose sciocche si
ha un minimo di esperienza non avrebbero
evitato un passo avanti e due indietro
come ora ma nessuno sapeva aiutarmi
ho combattuto contro ignoranza
pressapochismo modi di dire luoghi
comuni paure e ansie anche chi mi
sosteneva non sapeva che dirmi perché i
gemelli si possono anche allattare ma
chi lo ha mai visto fare un po matta o
fricchettona o antica o fissata persino
talebana mi sono sentito apostrofare le
parole
eppure nessuna di queste mi offendeva la
mia storia di latte è stata una storia
bellissima e perfettamente riuscita
ancora di più poi con la seconda coppia
di gemelle dove potevo finalmente
applicare tutto quello che avevo
imparato
a quel punto però ho sentito un'emozione
nuova
ho sentito come fondamentale addirittura
urgente riuscire a trasferire quello che
avevo imparato sulla mia pelle per
aiutare più mamme possibile a riuscire
visto che nessuno lo fa mi sentivo un po
così
il mondo va a fuoco e io solo posto
spegnerlo non c'è tempo da perdere
quindi visto che sono conifera attiva
incominciato a studiare e sono diventata
consulente allattamento e ho lavorato
nei distretti e ho lavorato negli
ospedali
però purtroppo si sa come funziona i
soldi per i nuovi corsi non ci sono le
usl e oasi come si chiamano non
investono e tutto diventa un po
difficile
e così abbiamo dovuto mollare tanto fa
umberto eco ricevette il plauso unanime
perché disse che facebook ha dato a
tutti i cretini l'opportunità di parlare
a un pubblico vasto ora io non sono
nessuno per contraddire il grande e
compianto eco ma uno strumento è uno
strumento dipende che uso ne fai con un
coltello si può uccidere una persona
sbucciare una mela a me che ho l'argento
vivo addosso questa la vita in parata
invece facebook ha dato l'occasione di
guardare davvero oltre l'orizzonte del
possibile di raggiungere il sogno di
cambiare il mondo
ho creato un gruppo allattamento materno
gemellare
ma oggi 1700 mamme gemellari da tutta
italia e anche da varie parti del mondo
allatta due o più gemelli anche grazie
al mio supporto ea quello delle
meravigliose moderatrici del gruppo
allora questo è il gruppo
l'allattamento materno gemellare a lato
dopo gemelli dicevo anche grazie al
supporto mio è quello delle meravigliose
moderatrici del gruppo che ogni giorno
eccole qua che ogni giorno ogni ora
aiutano rispondono ai dubbi alle paure e
alle ansie e allo sconforto di queste
mamme che si sentono così sole creando
una rete di solidarietà sostegno e di
amore
ogni cosa può diventare un'opportunità
anche quella che inizia con tanti nodi
datevi sempre l'opportunità di credere
di crescere di aiutare all'inizio fu il
verbo la mia parola
oggi è evoluzione grazie
[Applauso]